over the past few months we've seen
various celebrities taking on the tricky
bralette trend one of my favorites has
been Kendall she kind of lays it up a
little bit so she'll maybe wear a jacket
over the top or she'll wear a t-shirt
underneath this really caught my eye
because I think it's actually quite a
practical way to wear the growler it's
in a way that if you don't feel
confident about your clothing you can
still wear the trend another way that
you could wear the bra is actually even
for work which sounds pretty impossible
but it's not
I picked out this great shirt this is by
tibi which is one of my favorite brands
at the moment I love that it's got these
great toys please it's a bit of an
update on trade classic shirt I'd pop
little brawler over the top this is
whitey to often I love the combination
of the mustard with the pale blue
something like that even with the
sandals that I'm wearing here and it's
great for work I'm going to feel great
in a meeting with my editor out on press
days anything really I just think this
is such a great look another way that
you could wear the growler which to me
is quite an obvious way of wearing it
would be on holiday because we all want
to show off a bit of skin on holiday get
a bit of a suntan
this trial is quite tibi it's a lovely
stretchy cotton fabric and is that she
feels a little bit more supportive than
the bra that I'm wearing today so that's
going to make me feel a bit more
confident
I love these trousers they're by my
limberger again it's all about going to
something which is quite high waisted so
we're not showing a huge expanse of
flesh down here just throw a beach bag
with it on holiday nice pair of
sunglasses sorted
there's also quite a sporty way that you
can wear the bralette bike for instance
this little brawl at a head tuning it
with a sporty pair of trousers I
wouldn't put it to the Train and I think
you're going to go into sort of super
super sporty kind of a territory but
like where this is a great pair of heels
and for evening maybe throw a blazer
over the top some nice gold jewelry
that's something that I'm going to wear
all summer long and it's a really great
alternative to just wearing a boring
party dress if you want to see me
road-testing more tricky trends
subscribe to glamming pay
[Music]